you
hi everyone is Gerry on December 14 2014
magnus carlsen took part in an 11-game
cyma he played against 10 chess comm
members and one celebrity namely Rainn
Wilson also known as Dwight troupe from
America's TV series The Office just
about two years ago
Rainn the interviewed Magnus it's a fun
little interview I'll link that just to
the right of the board so you can check
it out
and just about one year ago Carlson was
once again playing against his celebrity
many of you know he played against Bill
Gates that game did not last long it was
only after nine moves and Bill Gates was
in checkmate
whenever a top chess player or in this
case a world champion is playing against
a celebrity the outcome is never in
doubt it's more of a question of well in
this case can Rainn Wilson last longer
than Bill Gates let's find out the time
controls were set at 25 minutes with a
25 second increment Magnus Carlsen had
the white pieces he opened with e4 Rainn
Wilson replying with g6 Knight f3 d6 d4
white has now this ideal pawn center
Bishop g7 Bishop c4 getting all the
minor pieces out black follows up with
Bishop g4 this is another minor piece
getting developed here unfortunately
it's a serious mistake at first glance
it appears quite alright since it is
restricting one of White's pieces the
knight in this case is pinned to the
Queen but at the same time the bishop is
unprotected and in this case it's
tactically vulnerable what now follows
as Bishop takes f7 and after King takes
Knight g5 does two things one attacks
the King in to tax the bishop and so
after the King moves the bishop will be
picked right back up and now taking
stock of this position black is simply
down upon Uncle dand has a serious
weakness in that of the e6 square a
better move instead of Bishop g4 would
have been Knight f6
getting another minor piece out
preparing to castle and at least at this
point if you want to play Bishop g4 this
tactic would not be on because the night
would be defending the bishop but as it
played out the bishop played there
immediately which does allow the tactic
and now has black in a very well
basically a losing position this is you
cannot stop the knight from getting into
this Square and it's just going to go
from bad to worse Knight h6 develops
with tempo on the Queen but she still
stays trained on this e six square which
means that the knight will simply not be
denied that post even if the Queen plays
up here to defend he would still jump in
there with great effect
so what stride is Knight d7 Knight II 6
hitting both Queen and Bishop rain saves
the more valuable piece Queen c8 but now
the bishop Falls with check and these
pieces are just falling like dominoes
unfortunately for black there goes the
bishop on g7 and there goes the knight
we're just about a dozen moves in and
black is down upon Knight Bishop and
remains well on castled so it's just a
matter of mopping this one up here
finishing things out getting completely
developed in other words white does just
that after castling on this move 15c
takes a takes we now have a half-open
efile a file that will soon be occupied
by both white rooks and this e 7 pawn
will soon collapse white coming in here
avoiding the Queen exchange white wants
more going right after the black King
piling up now on e7 black defends it for
the moment but after another piece is
added to it this square here is simply
going to collapse after Knight g4 rook
takes rook takes rook takes King c8
we're already at a point where it is a
checkmate in four if you'd like to go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the checkmate and for from this
position okay the solution here or how
this game finished up is as as follows
here with rook
eh check black only has one move one
legal move in each of these cases rook
takes Queen takes King see 796 that is a
fork the Queen could be one but y can do
one better after Queen b5 that's
checkmate and the game is over
after just these 28 moves but he did
last much longer than Bill Gates feel
free to share what your thoughts are on
this it's always for me at least a
little bit fun to see a celebrity play
against a top chess player just a fun
little question for those of you here on
YouTube how do you think Rainn Wilson
would do if he was to play against Bill
Gates and also do know that I've
provided a link in the description where
if you'd like to add Magnus Carlsen as a
friend on chess comm he does have an
account he's actually had one for a
little bit now but these are the only
games he's played thus far these eleven
games from the cyma like to add him as a
friend I've provided a link in the
description for you to do that and also
that link will allow you to also see the
other games that he played from this
Simon so that's all for this video I
hope you found it a little bit fun take
care bye
you